das fragen lotto mit giacomo tus genannt
socke unter anderem will ich von ihm zum
beispiel wissen beziehungsweise das
fragen ob ich würde es ja gar nicht mich
wird das ja gar nicht interessieren wann
hat er zum ersten mal ein mädchen
geküsst ist das bei dem man vielleicht
was später hat er überhaupt noch zeit
seine freunde zu treffen woher hat der
sein talent und wann war das letzte mal
beim friseur und außerdem wird er wenn
es gut geht das geheimnis seines
erfolges verraten also seid gespannt auf
diese frage wollte und wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ihr mehr von ihm und
von kriegsheim sehen wollt nach oben da
müsse der abo button sagt button sein
draufklicken und dann entgeht nichts
mehr so also hier fragen lotto
die roten sind gemeinde fragen ja die
grünen sind harmlose fragen darf selber
wählen du kannst bauen soll ich dann die
roten nehme ich solche was sagen ich
glaube gemein ist vielleicht ist also
das kann man auch schöner umschreiben
schwierige schwierige schwieriger
nämlich gerne aber keine mine aber weil
die meisten nehmen immer die roten
fahren weil die wissen wollen sehen was
für gemeinde sagen schwierigen zu hätte
schwierige fahren gemeint waren wurden
ja doch da sind auch unterstellungen
dabei also die sind auch die sind
wirklich aus der luft gegriffen aber
trotzdem sie sollen möglichst auch ernst
genommen werden ja auch wenn sie hast du
schon
mädchen begrüßt ja
selber anpacken du musst jetzt darauf
antworten ob es bei dem vergleich zum
beispiel später war weil du die ganze
zeit gespielt hast ich glaube nicht dass
uns jetzt wo sollte ich werde aus bei
anderen mal irgendwann im jugendlichen
alter
alles ganz normal alles ganz normal es
ist ja nicht anders da gibt es
sicherlich game war da gibt es
sicherlich nicht gamer die müssen später
dran sind aber das kann ja auch kein
großes ding finde ich es ist nur ein
großes ding wenn man bis 50 bei seiner
mutter
es ist ein chronist
muss schon weiter zu so habe ich das
einfach hierhin jack was ist ein
zusammenhang aller aufregung lindsay ist
da auch lustig ja
von wem hast du dann außergewöhnliches
talent das jetzt ist jetzt wohl ausgehen
wir laufen ja aus gaming natürlich der
weg ist wenn jemand gut singen kann sagt
man ach das hast du von deiner mutter
dem vater bei gaming ist das ein
bisschen der blöde frage ja weil deine
mutter oder den vater man sicher keine
aussage richtig guten ja das wenig
weiters gab es noch nicht ich habe
also im kindesalter so mit
computerspielen angefangen früher gab es
ja nur singleplayer sachen und ich habe
vielleicht vielleicht wegen mein bruder
das 5er älter als ich dann war ich da
sechs mal elf und dann haben wir da und
auch schon zusammen weiß ich nicht
knacken
ahlen gespielt und vielleicht kommt das
war ein bisschen aber du hast ihn dann
einfach mannschaft niemanden der die
großmutter nicht ich habe sondern weil
jemand pianist ich meine was
aggressionen oder
sekretäre mit viel
während sich das seien ich habe früher
auch jahrelange gespielt aber ich glaube
nicht dass es der fingerfertigkeit viel
gemacht hat das war ordentlich aber ich
glaube dass das
vielleicht überschätzt
doch dann hängt es nicht
also kannst du musst aber auch nicht
alle ziehen ich weiß nicht wie es bei
der jetzt denn nicht viele interviews
habe ich gehört auch der games kommen
also
noch auch wenn er es nicht eilig hatte
dann aber eher sind irgendwie entspannt
auch lustig ne plötzlich wird man
intermot ich meine in seinem
kinderzimmer angefangen hat am computer
spielt sich ja echt bescheuert ja aber
man gewöhnt sich dran ich freue mich auf
alle roten zettel irgendwas mit frauen
zu tun haben nein nicht komplett
reagierst du nicht allergisch auf
tageslicht nein wird ich glaube ich
würde sogar ziemlich schnell braun und
ok schweren sonnenbrand okay gut aber du
bist kein käse wie man ja auch
alles
nach los angeles hat einen sonnenbrand
da bin ich dann noch einen tag darum
gefahren
naja wie ist das ich glaube ich mir erst
mal auf und dann lese
wie ist das gefühl einer besten gamer in
deutschland zu sein
ist ein sehr schönes hotel durch glaubt
allgemein würden im besten irgendwas ist
oder einer der besten ist eine schöne
sache ist momente wurde manchmal denkt
so ja
ja vorhin viertelfinale gewonnen und
gelten hier wohl denkst du
nicht ganz ganz schön
wie oft im jahr geste zum friseur ich
habe das letzte mal
war das war nicht das ist ein halbes
jahr her oder so noch okay haben wir das
gefühl mich weiß davor war vor zwei
jahren oder so wie wir das schon
ordentlich letztes jahr haben andere
frisur und transport vom habe anderen
von
zwei jahren ich weiß es noch nicht so
genau also wann ich wieder lust zu zweit
ordentlich aussieht muss ja sind noch 33
kommen die man auch
bei welchem spiel hast du nicht am
meisten gefreut dass du ins nächste
level gekommen ist
computerspiel ins nächste level also ich
glaube nicht dass es da auch zwei hatten
nicht allzu viel medaillen zu tun sei
also mehr spieler vielleicht könnte man
die frage müssten anders formulieren
vielleicht aufs nächste level war 2002
die world cyber games
da wurde ich dann zweiter in deutschland
und ich bin ich für eine woche nach kuba
geflogen zum world final und das war
bisher glaube ich immer noch so mein
schönstes man schon ist sergej lawrow
2 lieber erst die rote genau wobei nähe
oder doch erst die rote kommt dennoch
etwas schönes persönliches
wann hast du das letzte mal etwas mit
seinen freunden und mit drei freunden
unternommen
also mit denen du wirklich auch so
freuen
ich überlege gerade richtig was
unternommen
also schon mal eine kleine beginn reicht
mir auch oder
also ich war letztens noch ein echtes
unterwegs also es inzwischen schon zwei
monate her
und dann zu machen ich glaube wir waren
ja klar aber ich war die letzten zwei
monate nicht entweder am reisen
auf einem event oder die zwei tage dann
lieber zum ausruhen oder vorbereiten auf
see ist jemand genutzt als als abends
trinken zu gehen dann habe ich kurz mal
ein fernsehabend macht zusammen gekocht
also richtig was unternommen das ist
schon eine weile her da völlig letzter
zeit zu viel zu tun
und jetzt die grünen also die ziehen sie
dann ja hat so ein bisschen getroffen
ja
was ist das geheimnis seines erfolges
das geheimnis ja hast du ein geheimnis
seines erfolgs ein geheimnis habe
nicht glaubt wirklich ein geheimnis habe
ich nicht also ich ausschlafen dass
bestimmtes es auch so ja also ich war so
im vergleich zu anderen ich glaube sehr
viel wert darauf dass ich auch solchen
ausstellung events
gut aus schlafe ich komme immer meistens
eine als eine der ersten morgens sind
zum aufwärmen und ich mache dann auch
schon gerne zwei drei stunden auf dem
anderen kommt erstmal bestimmte freuen
aber ich persönlich finde dass der
zustand in dem man auf events auf dem
event am wettkampf teilnimmt eine sehr
große rolle spielt also training macht
macht schon was aus aber es waren
bestimmt noch 20 prozent oder so die man
auswählen kann wird einfach guten
körperlichen zustand dann vielleicht
noch ein bisschen koffein ausgeschlafen
morgens geduscht vielleicht am abend
vorher sport gemacht und dann kann man
auch gut lassen auf den weg bringen hast
du mit dem aufwärmen für übungen für die
finger meine beine den main also ich hab
schon gelegt morgen & morgen gymnastik
zu machen im hotel aber ist man dann
noch zu blöd kann euch mal ein bisschen
wie recken und strecken
mit vielen dank bitte wird den optisch
gefreut dass freundlich trotz der vielen
fragen ja super